[Music]
wait this week we've got no chairs
allowed record-breaking rum and shocking
jewelry
take it away Tiffany yes so for our
first story there is a Japanese company
that is banning all of their employees
from sitting in order to be more
creative that's one of those immediate
yes knows in my mind he'll talk about
metal like you here and they're like yes
and then no at the same time no because
you're like but they're going to get
tired feet and the human right like that
comes in just to handle this movement
and then there's the yes part where
you're like but when you walk around
your arm were created so it does serve a
purpose do they have that that Stan
chair where you kind of lean on that
[ __ ] this is a stupid because you can't
force someone to be creative and there's
no one solution to be creative [ __ ]
stand and make a great movie
oh [ __ ] what you should do is given
those like workout medicine or medicine
balls but those workout balls so that
well yeah yeah with a dildo attached
yeah and then that kind of like a happy
compromise so they could stick that
build up their butthole and bounce I'm
creating I was so creativity are they
supposed to be standing up the whole
entire time like the whole [ __ ] or did
they have a good break well apparently
what this company does is that they sell
anything from electronics to storage
goods and what they're saying is that
under the new system in this company
they're going to implement these
shareable workstations
so all these employees have to share
these specific workstations whenever
they want to use the computer and
they'll have 45 minutes allotted to be
able to use that computer for that
amount of time standing this is the
photo that circulating everywhere
what is that Windows 95 so those
old-school is fun it's the most squares
monitoring I've ever seen - - is a
perfect split they don't believe in
[ __ ] HD they don't got 1080p there
yeah they're saying that they're
implementing this new policy so then
their place can be able to concentrate
better
you weren't creative even though there's
really no research-based facts that
really support that maybe it helps with
my blood flow and stuff because I know
that helps me like if I wake up and I
walk around bed Asians always making up
[ __ ] to [ __ ] come up with a
solution but they just make it up out of
thin air what are we going to do about
our employees they're too lazy how about
we make them stand and limit their
computer time so they can [ __ ] get
all the work done within that 45-minute
period window there's a booth [ __ ] man
you know what they should do for them to
be more creative is to let them be more
creative other kind of opposite to
American thinking you're not American
thinking if you go to like any of the
Google buildings they have a like
beanbag per square feet policy yeah so I
Google like there's a you know there's
usually like the unlit on the exact
board there's a CEO CFO CEO whatever
Google has a CCO which is a chief
culture officer and that person is just
to make sure that the culture of Google
and how dope it is stays a certain way
so for them they have to make sure
there's enough beanbags there's enough
like beer on tap to have enough drinks
custom chefs and all access to make sure
the employees are like super super well
taken care of
but none of the employees really take
advantage of that stuff because we're
hard-working as a hard worker they're
just too busy working that's the thing
too like a lot of people those how come
all companies don't do that it's like
well there's a reason why they're at
their position is because they have that
skill set and also the working
capability to do what they do yeah so
people who usually do that aren't
sitting around [ __ ] around all day so
that's just just in case they made it so
I know a lot of people who wish that you
know when I work for a company I want
them to do that to was like well your
entry-level job [ __ ] you're not
going to get those amenities that's true
because when Sega was around my cousin
worked for Sega and I will go to their
break room and everything and it's just
a full-on RK they have foosball all
kinds of [ __ ] and I'm like how you going
to get work done dude because I just be
in here all day but everyone's working
they're like making [ __ ] games and
[ __ ] maybe that's why Sega is not there
anymore is cuz
we playing the video games you know I
still have my ganger my Sega games yeah
I still have it cool do you guys feel
like you work better when you spin so
there's my emails I got to sit down and
I gotta like okay like this I can't even
listen to music when I answer emails
because it [ __ ] with my mind but then
if I'm trying to be creative I like
walking around and standing oh my like
this mental break right now
so I just don't do anything so I want to
see emails I just [ __ ] dodges and
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
ha ha ha I have I just cleared out a few
emails today which a few I mean by like
300
you should just highlight all and press
Delete but if I'm important [ __ ]
state of college did you get my email
I've never got it 72 no just romantic
yeah every time I passed by your altar
throw is laying down on your couch
watching family guy yeah that were the
office that's how he gets creative it's
true though he relaxed it is how I get
creative but I do watch a lot of films
and I watch a lot of comedy [ __ ] just to
keep the juices flowing depending on
what I'm watching also affects what I'm
writing too but family and I just said
because I'm [ __ ] around
that's so funny how the Asian ways to
control people more to try to make them
contribute it and then the white people
ways like how do we make people feel
free so they can like let their minds
open up and be creative
yeah
which anything is more effective the
Asian way of course how else do you
think Pokemon happened well I'm glad you
don't do that in this company mm-hmm
well because we're in America we have
rules here don't want to about the bunny
bit by to give your whole day man we
can't [ __ ] stab them like that so
they're not very well
all right by our next story you guys all
know it's your own ramen right yes Artic
come on right here because a baby goes
to New York
what like as a pop-up or what not a bit
of you oh I don't know I rather go to
Japan so baby
so really I don't know this is a photo
of it Iran's ramen and it looks exactly
like that that oh man using it's not
like other fast-food restaurants where
you see a picture and then you go there
and you're like what else that has me
that looks nothing like the [ __ ]
picture you sack a ball but in that one
it looks like the picture
Roz I drew that psycho Paul is making a
red velvet sack and then you're open is
your [ __ ] balls each neuron is you
like be in and out of rama's oh yeah
everything's in and out for you
and it not to me is like the standard of
what a restaurant should be yeah every
time you go to a [ __ ] in and out no
matter where you go what city wherever
it's at if it be exact same way I've
never eaten in an Alberto I was like
this was not as good as the other one
idea big Tasty's anything yeah I don't
know how they [ __ ] do it or how well
they train their people but they [ __ ]
kill it actually in Texas I've had in
and out and I was like I don't know if
it's the florist and lights but the bun
was a little bit browner
like wheat bun I was like what the
hell's going on the lettuce is a little
bit different maybe they got it from New
Mexico I don't know it could have been a
what a burger secret agent Abbott hasta
in and out in Austin bringing it back to
them
no I don't put your location in Taiwan
because it's a neighbor do if they put
it you have my long con snitch could
it's a neighbor is it at a Friday also
Italian Thai so lousy for one if I pay
Oh typing
I told you I know Thailand anyway so
this restaurant is very loved by
everyone because of the amazing wrong
and because of the experience when you
go dine in one of the restaurants they
like like section you off in your own
little individual home and you get to
enjoy ramen you could take the divider
off and have a date yeah you can was the
reason why they like to do this and so
you can only focus on the amazing moment
why not forcing you in the Taiwan of
State and have one in Arcadia so when
they open this new location they broke
the world record for longest standing
continuous line and their line was 250
hours that's [ __ ] 10 days straight
isn't it Monday's see I want to own a
business like that I don't know how
these people like food omelet yeah
there's a 20% you know they do remember
was a 85 degrees know what it was like a
bakery that your uncle took us to that
it is all that line eighty-five degrees
before they came I years ago and then my
uncle is like you gotta try this bakery
it's the [ __ ] [ __ ] and they're going
to open one and uh America but I don't
believe them because that's what they
always say don't go let's go to go to
America cause is so awesome not
everywhere yeah I know when I came here
my uncle was in mind this time he
usually does uh yeah he always he's
always saying [ __ ] this thing's gonna go
to America oh yeah right they answered
quito Cambridge so it was it open 24
hours early you know what the thing
about 24 restaurants is hard to keep
clean they do a good job somehow do you
think they shipped over Japanese slaves
to do this in Taiwan but come on these
people are teasing they trained the
Taiwanese people there
I love Taiwan man I like Taiwan to in
this that place
- they're the [ __ ] human ass weather
but the food is dope coming November
yeah November December anywhere you like
spring here oh really you're marking
April here because it was I went in
January it's like winners still [ __ ]
hot if you wear like bubble jacket oh
yeah man we went in November and people
were wearing like heavy ass jacket and
we were like in tank tops because I mean
that's just my way I just came from
Taiwan and we're hanging out with the
two days ago and it was like 90 degrees
right through a jacket she's wearing a
jacket and then as soon as my cousin
turned on the AC and the caution I can
catch on and off I'm like what the [ __ ]
were dying right now
oh my god how many people are crazy did
your mom is the same she gets cold
really uselessly I kind of a thesis
heart is different though oh [ __ ]
where's what's gonna mess up her energy
and then her muscle get all tight the
[ __ ] cold dragon is going to come in
and bade your private parts it's so hot
in Taiwan the most people don't care
about what they look like or dress like
so they all look terrible like because
it's too hot to care about what you're
[ __ ] wearing everyone's [ __ ] neck
part is like Sujatha is too [ __ ] hot
men like sweaty Asians nah
anyway it's hot and [ __ ] human but
for me I just like to straight through
so much I don't give a [ __ ] there's a
lot of mosquitoes up hot time you had to
put off spray like a [ __ ] you
start raising alright for our last story
there was a Chinese woman that fainted
after she accidentally brought a $44,000
Jade bracelet
bad luck 44,000 birthday bracelet she
hit her ear to visit a museum so this is
what the bracelet look like after part
of the exact way did she break it in the
store was that hers in the place of
where you buy it
this is store why would they have a
$44,000 bracelet in a swap meet
yes I was thinking soon like why would
you let somebody hold it yes you dropped
it on the floor which is taking it off
her wrist that's stupid
Swamy is a good question though why is
that a their [ __ ] flies from the
butcher next door I know so I'm gonna
show you guys a video that someone got
of her when she fainted their start or
not the moment she fainted I guess it
was in China in China I would have
fainted - I would - oh my god Eli I know
she's this like connected yeah no here
[ __ ] lines I don't want to pay for
nothing man
cuz I've seen real people faint and
that's not a faint - lady she fainted
from the price dude like thinking I
could she fainted as soon as she heard
the price don't you like no see that
faint is so [ __ ] overdramatic bet you
do not [ __ ] faint I could tell
because that seemed a lady faint before
and it's like their whole box or I mean
her eyes look at that [ __ ] you're not
[ __ ] you [ __ ] liar I've seen people
faint all the time always all the time I
wanted to be taken away from the
ambulance how the week is even here like
they're out what if I was the store
owner I would slap her [ __ ] back to
health man see even that right there her
sitting on that [ __ ] you can't do that
when you say man I saw a lady state at
24 hours
it's crazy flex party is just a ziploc
bag full of water you know [ __ ] your
life dude her face was like this I'm not
gonna pay nothing yeah when you see so
much that's not a dude you [ __ ] lyin
ass [ __ ] agent agent ladies are
[ __ ] around
she's like him to the car be smart or
than her fault
I was slapper Nana's house blacker look
ah yeah your leg now aren't you [ __ ]
paper price what do you think would
happen when she wakes up do you think
they're going to make her pay for it
well it is reported that the owner was
offered 70,000 Yann which is about like
a little over $10,000 in damages by the
woman's family but then the owner
refused saying that this thing is worth
forty's more than 44,000 euro sellers
and that's when the family all painted
ha ha ha ha
Yahweh Wow
yes the lesson they found out the family
found out by an independent expert who
reportedly said that that bracelet was
not worth forty four thousand plus it
was actually closer to twenty six
thousand that makes sense
that's very Asian of people too [ __ ]
overpriced means yeah so then that's
what the family agreed to pay that
twenty six thousand nothing nothing out
of it they get two broken Jade pieces
have I got these pieces can even mold I
should bet is rock if you have melted or
some [ __ ] right you can't melt it nah no
rock no you can't believe Ken that's how
you get glass well it turns into
something else had any tape it you have
to polish and smooth like it's all
chiseled and smooth and yes moved out
it's not a mold sees your this is your
turf how do they do it I don't know but
both my aunts Jade bracelet should be my
god you are such a troublemaker dude
there's never a good story about your
childhood you should have seen how my
are cheated me
she why would grown-ass woman trying to
[ __ ] with a kid I don't know he was
probably a piece of [ __ ] kid hey what's
up guys thanks for watching we are going
to regularly start posting content on
the JK films Instagram so make sure you
follow us there allows video click over
here
[Music]